نتحول بكم مباشره الى صنعاء وبيان العميد
يحيى سريع المتحدث العسكري باسم جماعه
انصار الله الحوثي سفينه شحن عسكريه
امريكيه اوشن جاز في خليج عدن وذلك
بصواريخ بحريه مناسبه ان القوات المسلحه
اليمنيه تؤكد ان الرد على الاعتداءات
الامريكيه والبريطانيه قادم لا محاله وان
اي اعتداء جديد لن يبقى دون رد وعقاب ان
القوات المس حه اليمنيه تؤكد استمرارها في
منع السفن الاسرائيليه او المتجهه الى
موانئ فلسطين المحتله حتى وقف العدوان
ورفع الحصار عن الشعب الفلسطيني في قطاع
غزه ان القوات المسلحه اليمنيه مستمره في
اتخاذ كافه الاجراءات الدفاعيه
والهجوميه ضمن حق الدفاع عن اليمن العزيز
وتاكيدا على استمرار الموقف اليمني
المساند لفلسطين
ان القوات المسلحه اليمنيه مستمره في الرد
على اي اعتداء امريكي او بريطاني على
بلدنا وذلك باستهداف كافه مصادر التهديد
في البحرين الاحمر والعربي والله حسبنا
ونعم الوكيل نعم المولى ونعم النصير عاش
اليمن حرا عزيزا مستقلا والنصر لليمن ولكل
احرار الامه صنعاء الحادي عشر من رجب
1445 للهجره الموافق للثان من يناير
204 صادر عن القوات المسلحه اليمنيه